für die günstigste milchschnitte der
welt streckt sebastian sahne mit fett
und wasser aufgepumpt mit gas wird die
dann auch so richtig fluffig süß und
luftig ganz nach dem geschmack der
industrie wir machen heute sein ersatz
genau so geschmeidig genau so cremig
aber nicht so fett und aus ganz anderen
zutaten bei genauem hinsehen hat das
alles mit sahne die mich zu tun
[Musik]
sehr viel wasser
und künftiges gibt es ist keineswegs
besseres fed einfach nur anderes fett
anderes feld heißt in diesem fall prüfen
dazu brauchen wir noch etwas weißes
pulver damit fett und wasser
zusammenhalten
das ist xanthan ein kalb in der das
wasser gemisch cremig lisa aussehen
lässt mit peter lohse dass die sahnigen
kalten zustand trotzdem noch flüssig
lässt dann kann tatsächlich noch eine
zutat die zumindest entfernt etwas mit
milch zu tun hat
milchpulver damit schönweiß ist für den
mädchen geschmack was fehlt ist echte
sahne
das war's nur noch einmal gut durch mixa
[Applaus]
aussehen tut es schon mal die ferne
immerhin
natürlich darf man das ich sagen es ist
immer noch sein ersatz aus wasser
pflanzenfett milcheiweiß bindemittel
billig hergestellt aber teuer verkauft
im vergleich zu handelsüblicher seine
kosten die ersatzprodukte fast das
doppelte
herrlich sonnig und luftig locker
milchprodukte schmecken besonders gut
wenn's cremig ist deshalb verwandelt die
industrie quark pudding und viele andere
desserts gerne in einen herrlich
leichten schauer selbst frischkäse mögen
viele in der aufgeschäumten variante am
liebsten und füllungen von riegeln oder
schnitten kommen beim kunden auch nur
gut an wenn sie schön fluffig sind und
er tritt für jede kollegin ist einfach
nur ein bisschen gas sebastian legis
creme soll später nach dem aufräumen
möglichst lange stabil bleiben
das erledigen cover gen stärke oder work
als mangel steif möchte schon oma sowas
in die schlagsahne
aber hier geht es noch weiter nur sahne
zu nehmen wäre natürlich erst mal extrem
teuer deswegen strecken wir mit
magermilchpulver und das liebste
streckmittel was war eigentlich könnte
man jetzt einfach alles mit dem
schneebesen luftig schaumig schlagen
doch luft enthält sauerstoff und der
lässt die masse in kurzer zeit verderben
die industrie hat dagegen ein geniales
rezept
[Musik]
jetzt kommt unser kleiner zaubertrick
stickstoff speziell für lebensmittel der
nicht reagiert mit unseren anderen
zutaten die war gleich oben in unsere
säule kippen werden als bestandteil der
luft ist stickstoff völlig ungefährlich
in reinform jedoch kann er uns ersticken
stopp dafür aber auch natürliche
zersetzungsprozesse in lebensmitteln in
der fabrik passiert das aufschäumen mit
stickstoff in geschlossenen systemen
doch zur demonstration des verfahrens
hat sebastian lege etwas improvisiert
[Musik]
was für eine schweinerei dass hat man
gesehen
die masse richtig aufgepumpt ist nach
oben tja jetzt müssen wir den schlauch
noch befreien aus der säule wie man
sehen kann
das ist hier keine saubere angelegenheit
viel creme aus wenig masse und dann der
unsichtbaren zauber zutat stickstoff ist
die füllung für sebastian lege
sahneschnitte im kühlschrank nicht nur
tage sondern mehrere monate lange
haltbar
die haltbarkeit ist für kunden und
einzelhandel ein großer vorteil
[Musik]
[Applaus]
sie auf alle fälle schon mal ganz gut
aus schönes verhältnis zwischen boden
und geben
auf alle fälle noch nicht perfekt aber
luftig locker auf alle fälle gestreckt
mit fett und aufgepumpt mitgas schreckt
das ab bei euren süßigkeiten sagt es uns
in den kommentaren
und wenn ihr noch mehr über ihr essen
wissen wollt dann abonniert die zdf
besser esser und schaut in die nächsten
zwei clips